عمل طاهي في بدايه حياته ثم قام ربيع شقته
مقابل بدعه عملات من البيتكوين قبل ان
ينتهي به الامر الاعتلاء عرش العملات
المشفره في العالم انه الصينيجبين المعروف
بسيزي فما قصته ولد
الصينيه عام
1977 وكان والده استاذا باحدى الجامعات
الصينيه الرائده ووالدته معلمه وفيما كان
يجب ان يحيى حياه مستقره ببلاده وجد نفسه
وهو في سن الثانيه عشر يفر مع والدته الى
كندا نتيجه الاضطرابات التي شهدتها البلاد
في الثمانيات قد تشاو سنوات مراهقه في
التنقل بين الوظائف الحره كما عمل طاهي
برجر في ماكدونالدز قبل ان يدرس علوم
الحاسوب بعد التخرج عملت شاؤوا مقاب في
بورصه طوكيو ثم انتقل لنيويورك للعمل في
شركه بلومبيل تريد بوك مطولا للبرامج
الحاسوبيه في عام 2005 انتقلت شو الى
شنغهاي واسس شركه فيوجن سيستمز لتكنولوجيا
المعلومات والاستشارات التجاريه عمل باكثر
من شركه ناشئه قبل ان ينضم لكادر منصه
بلوكشن دوت انفو كمطور المحافظ الرقميه ثم
انتقل الى شركه اوكي كوين وعمل رئيسا فنيا
في مجال العملات المشفره لكن اهتمامه
الفعليه فيها بداك مستهلك من خلال لعبه
البوكر حيث قام صديقه بتعريفه على عمله
البيتكوين فانغمس في هذه السوق حتى انه
باع منزله لشراء بدعه عملات منها في عام
2015 اسست شاو شركه بجتاك لتداول العملات
المشفره بشانغهاي الا انها انتهت بعد
عامين وبشكل مفاجاه ليظهرت شو مع مشروع
جديد هو منصه باينس حيث حصل على تمويلا ب
15 مليون دولار كان ذلك في يوليو عام 2017
لكن الصين وبعد اسابيع قليله حضرت تداول
العملات المشفره فانتقلت الشركه خارج
البلاد لم يكن ذلك فقط فقد تعرضت المنصه
في عام 2019 لعمليه سرقه بما قيمته 40
مليون دولار لكن الشركه تعوضت العملاء كما
واجهت شركه تحديات اخرى عندما انخفضت قيمه
عملتها البي ان بي بشكل كبير وحينها قادت
تشاو جهودا كبيرا لتحويل الشركه الى
الاداره لا مركزيه ما سمح بمنحها مزايا
مميزه للمستخدمين ورغم ان بين ازواجها
التحقيقات امنيه في عده دول وتم حظرها في
المملكه المتحده فقد اثبت منتجها انه
مقنعه واصبح بدل منصه فريق المنتشر في
اكثر من 40 دوله حول العالم ومع اكبر
بورصه للعملات المشفره في العالم بات
المهاجر الصيني يتربع على عرش العملات
المشفره مع ثروه تقدر باربعه مليارات و500
مليون دولار